[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE SORVILLO: My
name is Mike Sorvillo.
I'm a product manager on the
Hangouts Chat bot framework.
I'm here today with Wesley,
one of our G Suite developer
advocates and Chuan, the
technical lead for the Hangouts
Chat bot framework.
So today we're going
to talk about how
you can transform your workplace
with a Hangouts Chat bot
framework.
And just a quick
agenda, I'm going
to give some background
about the new Hangouts Chat
and bot's user
experience in case you
guys have never tried
the product before.
I'm going to pass it
off to Wes and Chuan
to talk about the
bot framework in API.
And show you a ton of
code samples and demos
before I wrap it up.
So a quick show of hands,
how many people in the room
use Hangouts today in
Gmail or on mobile?
Awesome.
So what you might not know is
that millions of businesses
use Hangouts today for direct
messaging or lightweight group
messaging with their company.
And what we've heard
from these companies
is that they're looking
for a more persistent place
for their teams to
collaborate and communicate.
So this past February, we
launched the new Hangouts Chat.
It's currently available
for G Suite customers
at no additional charge.
It's a brand new tech
stack with apps on macOS,
Windows, Android, iOS, and web.
It's global out of the gate.
So it works in 28
languages and is
accessible on all major screen
readers on all major platforms.
And really, the backbone
of the new Hangouts Chat
are rooms, a way to center the
conversation around a team,
a project, an event,
basically anything you want.
And it's obvious when
you're working on a project,
you're going to be talking about
a bunch of different things.
I'm sure everyone in the room
has experienced this if you've
used group messaging before.
You maybe are talking about
something important, something
at work, about work.
And then all of a sudden,
someone in the message
is like, hey guys, what do
you want for lunch today.
And then the work keeps
going on and that's great.
But then all of a sudden,
someone else, who's probably
hungry, says I want Mexican.
So when this happens,
it's really hard
to just figure out
what's happening
and what's the conversation
we should be focused on.
So conversations in
rooms are threaded
to prevent this exact problem.
Threading helps you separate
the everyday chit chat from all
of the important stuff.
And not only that, you can
segment the important stuff
by different threads
to keep context
around those conversations.
If you use Google
Groups for email lists
or identity management
at your company,
you can add a Google
Group to a room
and then anyone in the room
can also join the room.
Over time, these rooms
are going to contain
all the things
you've talked about,
all the files you've
shared, so everything
is fully indexed and searchable
and you can look for file type,
keyword, person, look
in one room, many rooms,
basically however you remember
what you're looking for.
Hangouts Chat has deep
integrations into G Suite.
So you can pick any docs or
drive file from the drive file
picker.
And any time you paste
a drive file or docs
file, a link to it, we
will render a thumbnail
and help you grant access
to everybody in the room.
And if you find yourself
going back and forth too much
with someone or writing
blocks and blocks of text,
we help you, with one
click, up the bandwidth
of the conversation by
creating a video meeting
with our sister
product Hangouts Meet.
So anyone in the room
can jump in the meeting,
and you can resolve what you
wanted to resolve faster.
So you're all no stranger to
conversational interfaces.
We saw some pretty amazing
things from the Assistant team
yesterday at the keynote.
And bots at the workplace, what
they're really meant to do,
is help you blend
conversation and tools
to accelerate your work
and reduce all that context
switching that
happens when you're
working with a bunch of
different tools at work.
You can talk to a bot privately
in a one-on-one direct message.
Or you can add a bot to a room,
and then anyone in the room
can @mention it to do something.
And while you can take
anything and make it
a conversational interface,
you can literally
take a 12 page form and make
it a conversational interface.
We really think
conversational interface
is shine for three main
use cases at the workplace.
One is asynchronous
notifications.
So in use case, something
happens in a third party app
and a notification gets
plumbed into the room
where everyone can start
a conversation about it.
Another is one-off actions.
So in this case, maybe
you're talking about someone
about what you need to do.
And then you say, hey
project management bot,
create a task about this item.
And it does that.
And the third is
querying for information.
So with this use case,
there's data, obviously,
in the third party app.
And you just want to find it.
So you say, project
management bot,
what are Mandy Tiller's tasks.
And it shows you
what the tasks are.
One of our big mantras
on the Hangout Chat team
is that bots are people too.
They live alongside people and
there's no heavy instillation
flow, nothing more to learn.
If you know how to start a
direct message with someone,
add someone to a room,
@mention someone,
you know how to get
started with a bot.
Google launched a few
bots of their own.
One is the Meet bot that uses
natural language processing
and machine learning to schedule
a meeting and book a room
for everybody in the room.
Another is the Google
Drive bot that notifies you
when new files are shared with
you, new comments are made,
or when people request
access to your files.
And not only can you see
when people request access,
but you can actually grant
access from the bot itself.
In fact, in the two months
since launching, what we've seen
is that people
typically grant access
to files with the
Google Drive bot
eight times faster than
they do with email.
So think about that.
You can actually speed up a
common workflow for any app
that you build by eight times.
We have a number of third
party bots like Trello
to stay informed about
your project's progress
without leaving the chat room.
Ringcentral to make calls
or start videoconferences
with your room and your team.
Jira, so you can get
notified about changes
to issues, tasks, bugs.
And then talk about those
changes as they happen.
And we're excited
to announce today
that box is launching a bot on
Hangouts Chat to help you find
recent files or
favorite files to open
or share without
switching context.
We have a number of bots
and many different business
functions, like developer
tools, tasks, CRM, HR, support,
and more.
So now I'm going to pass
this over to Wes and Chuan
to talk a bit about the
bot framework and API.
WESLEY CHUN: Great.
Thanks, Mike.
All right, we're
here to guide you
on this comprehensive tour for
the bot framework for Hangouts
Chat.
So what we just
saw from Mike are
a bunch of public bots written
by others and they're available
for everyone.
But what I want you
guys to think about
is writing bots on your own.
Whether it be for
your organization,
for your customers,
or the world,
you know, write a public
bot like the others
that you've seen.
But maybe you're new to bots.
And you're kind of
like hesitating,
going, you know, how hard is it?
But you know, put simply
it's not that bad.
Just think of bots as
like microservices.
They're simpler.
There's less code.
And you don't have to write it a
complete web app or mobile app.
You don't have that complexity.
So less code means you can
build your apps quicker.
But how quick?
Well, the Motorola
CIO got a demo bot up
in less than an hour,
then, of course,
spent a bit more time
to do one for real work.
What does it do?
It talks to multiple
systems and it
gathers customer order and
device warranty information
to present to
perhaps the customer
service agent who needs
this information when
they're on a call.
The main idea is
that humans used
to have to log into
each of these systems
separately by hand, collate all
that information before they
could tell their customer.
But now with the bot, you can
summarize all these results
from all these different systems
together in a single room
so that all the CSRs can
see this at the same time.
Some more on the blog
post, but we're here
to help get you started.
All right, well,
building quickly
isn't the only standout
feature of Hangouts Chat.
We want to emphasize
that the platform has
a lot of flexibility.
There's many different ways to
implement and host your bots.
So we're going to go
over some of the basics
and then walk you through
each option that you see here.
All right, so a quick
review, talking to APIs
and then comparing
that with bots.
So in this diagram, we
have an application.
We need to try and reach an API.
The data is protected
behind OAuth.
And so what typically
has to happen
is the user has to grant
access to your application
through OAuth.
You guys have seen that
little dialog window, right?
And once that happens, then the
app is able to reach the API,
access that users secure
data on their behalf,
do all the work
that it needs to,
and then respond back
to the user, right?
Everybody familiar with this?
OK, great.
So with bots, it's a little
bit different, all right.
It's kind of a three
tier architecture here.
And what happens is,
instead of a request coming
from an application,
the request really
comes from a user
in a chat room.
All right, they enter.
I want to talk to this bot.
I'm going to send
it this payload.
So that message gets
entered into Hangouts Chat.
Then Hangouts Chat
contacts your bot.
Your bot does all the
work it needs to do,
collates the
information, and then it
returns that information
back to Hangouts Chat
which then renders that
result in the chat room, OK.
So it's a little bit different.
The key takeaway here is
that for your regular apps,
you call APIs.
But with bots, Hangouts
Chat calls you, all right?
So noodle on this for a moment
and once you kind of got this,
then the implementation path
that you are going to take
is going to be more clear, and
you can build your bots faster.
All right, now the
most efficient bots
return plain text because
it's short, it's fast,
and it gets the job done.
But for a better
user experience,
Hangouts Chat
supports richer UIs
called cards that allow you to
structure your response data.
For example, if you look
at the card sample here,
you could see that
your bot could
have returned five lines of
plain text and done its job.
But this UI card is
more pleasing visually.
In fact, if you communicate
more than just plain text,
for example, you can see
that there's a visual cue
to show that two of the
five have been completed
from this project
management bot that's
managing one of your reports.
So that visual cue
is really helpful.
And if you were to do
that in plain text,
you'd have to add some
extra symbols, which
may get in the way of the
data that's coming back.
So cards are great.
We'll look at them a
little bit more later.
Now, if you already have an app
with data that's kept secure
behind OAuth, you
can still expose
some of your app functionality
within Hangouts Chat.
Our auth and config flow lets
your users log into your app
directly from Hangouts Chat.
Now, it's similar
to this example
where you see the task tracker
bot which stores information
on a Google sheet.
Well, you know, the sheet
is protected data, right?
So the user has to allow your
bot access to that spreadsheet.
And then once the
auth's flow is complete,
then users can now access
your app and their secure data
directly from Hangouts Chat
room and direct messages.
All right, before
showing you the code,
I want to give you a quick
rundown of the event types
that Hangouts Chat
sends to your bot.
So your bot can take action
when it is, for example,
added to a space.
This is a great place to send
a welcome message like, hey,
thanks for adding
me to this room.
Here's how to use me.
It also can take action when
its removed from a space,
like logging things or doing
some kind of cleanup business
logic.
The most common event
type is message,
which is just when
a bot receives
a normal message entered
by a user in a room or DM.
And then the last
one is card clicked,
which is when a user clicks
on one of the UI card elements
that we just looked at earlier.
So to keep things
simple, we are going
to focus on the latter pair.
All right, let's start
with standard bots
that are running over HTTP.
As mentioned before, the
development environment
is quite flexible.
Bots can be created and
hosted on any platform.
In other words, your language,
your stack, your cloud or ours.
So I presented at the top here
some Google Cloud Platform,
or GCP, products and Firebase
products that you could use,
but you don't have to.
So Hangouts Chat also works
with bot-related environments
like Dialogflow and Hubot.
We'll demo some bots in some
languages that you see here.
But it really doesn't matter.
As long as the Hangouts
Chat service can HTTP
post to your bot, that's
all that's really necessary.
All right, are you guys
ready for your hello world?
We're going to start
with the Echo bot,
and happy to pass
it off to Chuan,
who's the engineering lead
for the Hangouts Chat bot
framework.
CHUAN JI: All right, thank you.
Hi, let's switch
to demo, please.
All right, can
everybody see my screen?
Great.
Cool.
So for those of you
haven't used Hangouts Chat
before, what you're seeing
right now on my screen
is the Mac OS desktop
app for Hangouts Chat.
So on the left,
you'll see a list
of rooms and direct messages
that I'm a member of.
And on the right, you
will see a message stream.
So I can scroll up a little bit.
And I can see the group
conversations and so on.
And of course, I can create
a new conversation here.
So now, let's take a
look at a very basic bot.
I'm going to call it the echo
bot, which simply writes back
whatever the user sends to it.
So I'm going to talk
to it here, got bot.
Hi.
And it's going to
say hi back to me.
All right.
Cool.
So you saw that the
way I talked to a bot
is by mentioning
it in a message.
So in rooms, only messages
that directly mention a bot get
sent to the corresponding bot.
So the rest of your conversation
with your team is private.
This is not the only way
you can talk to a bot.
You can also have
a direct message,
a one-on-one direct
message with the bot.
So here you can see I
already have a direct message
with the Echo bot as well.
And here you can
see I don't have
to mention the echo bot at all.
Every message I say
in this direct message
is going to be sent to
this bot because that's
the only other person
in this direct message.
So now that we've seen
how you could interact
with the echo bot
in Hangouts Chat,
let's take a look
at how it's built.
Let's go back to the slides.
WESLEY CHUN: All
right, so here's
the echo bot in full
glory in Python.
This example uses the
popular flask web framework,
which is hostable on App Engine,
Compute Engine, or really
any cloud-supporting
Python web apps.
As you can see from the
top of the function there,
Hangouts Chat posts to slash.
And the code scans the JSON
payload for the message type.
And then it returns the
same message string along
with the user and the user name
of whomever called the bot.
Just like in Chuan's
demo that you just saw.
Now Python isn't
the only choice.
For example, maybe
you have a mobile app
and you're using Firebase,
well if all of your code
is on Firebase, you don't
really necessarily want
to host your bot on something
completely different.
That's perfectly fine.
So here's the same
bot in Node.js
and hosted by Cloud
Functions for Firebase.
If instead, most of
your back end is on GCP,
then you can host it
on the sister product,
Google Cloud Functions.
The code will be
nearly identical.
So if you take a look
at the code here,
it does pretty much the same
thing as all the others.
It scans the inbound
message for a message event,
then it returns a user
name and string as before,
and it really doesn't
matter to Hangouts Chat
that your code isn't
JavaScript or Python
and hosted on Cloud Functions
for Firebase or Google Cloud
Functions.
Remember, Hangouts
Chat only knows
how to HTTP post to your bot.
All right, so how are
you guys doing so far?
Want to see more code?
All right.
Switching gears a little
bit, let's talk a bit
about Google Cloud Pub/Sub.
So what is it?
Many of you know
that it's a real time
event streaming and
messaging system where
you can have many
producers and consuming
reading and writing and
probably at different rates.
And all, of course,
could be coming
from different applications.
But what does this have
to do with Hangouts Chat?
Well, the platform is supposed
to be flexible, right?
What if you decide to
host your bot on premise
and behind a firewall.
Well, in this case, Hangouts
Chat cannot contact your bot.
So what can you do?
Well, this is a perfect
use case for Pub/Sub.
Hangouts Chat sends a message
to Pub/Sub instead of your bot
because it can't reach it.
Your bot has to register
a pull subscription which
allows the bot to
get the Hangouts Chat
messages from Pub/Sub and
bring it through the firewall.
And then your on premise bot
can service the requests,
do all the calls it needs
to do, it gathers up
all the information, and then
responds back to Hangouts Chat
like normal.
All right, let's
see how to use it.
So in the next example, is a
Java version of the echo bot,
OK.
Because a lot of
enterprises use a Java,
and so we want to show an
example in this language
as well.
So like Python and Node, you
can see that the code handles
the event.
It scans for message type.
And then it replies to Hangouts
Chat with a message text
and username.
It's just like the others,
but perhaps maybe a tiny bit
more verbose, right?
Well, that's great.
But what if this bot is
in our corporate data
center behind that firewall?
Well, we just
mentioned a minute ago
that Pub/Sub is
the right solution.
So how do we tweak our bot
code to work with Pub/Sub?
Well, it turns out
it's not too bad.
So if you look over here,
you can see the extra code
that we added to
our Java Echo bot
that uses object mapper to
convert between JSON and Java
objects.
It's then able to get
the message from Pub/Sub
and convert it to
JSON for processing.
It passes that event
object to the handle method
that we saw in the previous
slide, which then handles
a message as if it was sent via
HTTP posts from Hangouts Chat.
It doesn't know the difference.
All right, so that's awesome.
All right, so we
discussed hosting
on Google's cloud, your cloud,
with or without a firewall.
Let's bring it back inside
Google with a little twist
called Google Apps Script.
But first things
first, quick quiz.
How many of you feel it's
important to have auth to help
keep your user's data secure?
Right, yeah, me too.
Now, how many of you
like writing auth code?
Yeah, chirp, chirp, chirp.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
What about managing
your own servers or VMs
on premise or in the cloud?
Not easy either, right?
So in that case, App
Script is for you.
Have you heard of
App Script before?
How many of you have ever
heard of App Script before?
Well, a couple of you.
That's good, but not enough.
It's kind of like another Google
secret, but just not a good one
because we launched it
almost a decade ago.
So what is it?
It's a customized
JavaScript environment
where we take care of
the servers and auth.
And you have access to
more than 40 G Suite
and Google APIs with
just function calls.
Now, if you try to
build a bot with it,
we actually provide you
a one-click bot template
so that you're already
given a basic working bot
to hack on right away.
Check out the video if you want
to learn more about the secret.
All right, so App Script
is a serverless environment
for all developers, including
sometimes developers,
like all you product
folk, business analysts,
and data scientists out there.
Now, here's the @Echo
bot inn Apps Script.
Now, let's pause for a minute
here, really look at this code.
While it's identical in
functionality as the others,
it's only one line of code.
One line.
And not only that,
it's the easiest way
to deploy a bot within
your organization.
All right, so the Echo
part is a good start.
But Chuan, can you show us a
more useful Apps Script bot?
CHUAN JI: Sure.
All right, so just
like the Echo bot,
we're going to show
you a very quick bot
that's takes in the user input.
But instead of just
returning it verbatim,
I'm going to do a little twist.
We're going to translate it.
OK, so let's switch to demo.
Already here, all right.
So I've called
the translate bot.
And I'm going to say welcome
to Google I/O in English.
And it's giving to us back the
same message but in Japanese.
Cool.
So let's take a look
at how that's built.
Let's go back to
the slides, please.
OK here it is.
Notice how it's almost
as simple as the robot
the only difference is that
we are now calling the Google
Translate API.
And how do we call the
Google Translate API?
It's just a function
call away, right?
You're not importing SDK,
you're not downloading anything,
it's just there.
And you can see how it's
very intuitive to use.
You pass the message
the user sent.
In this case, it's
e.message to argument text.
Our human text
being the text you
just sent without the
bot's own name in it.
And you pass it the source
language and the target
language.
And they return
the result as text.
That's it.
It's almost too simple, right?
Let's take a look at a more
advanced example, cool.
So that's the demo again.
So in preparation for
this talk, our team
has been using Google
Spreadsheets to track all work.
OK, so each of us has
some task assigned.
And I built a simple bot to
take a look at where everyone
is at in terms of their tasks.
So I call it the
task tracker bot.
So I'm going to call it here.
OK, so it looks like we have
a bunch of tasks pending here.
So let's take a look
at the spreadsheet.
Can you guys see
the spreadsheet?
OK.
So you can see this is a
plain Google Spreadsheet.
The first row with the column
names and a bunch of tasks
here, assignee, and status.
So you can see the bot is
really pulling the data
from the spreadsheet that's
showing the tasks that are not
yet completed.
So I'm going to mark all
of these completed right
now since we're already
standing on the iOS stage.
I'm going to mark
everything as completed.
And I'm going to go
back to the chat app.
And I'm going to query it again
through my task tracker bot.
And this time it's
going to tell us
that there are no more tasks.
Hooray.
The video's coming
soon, by the way.
All right, let go to the slides.
So this is the code.
This is the code for
the Task Tracker bot.
And you can see it
fits on one slide.
So it's really not
that complicated.
You can see we're doing
some processing here.
We're opening up the spreadsheet
by SpreadsheetApp.openById.
We're grabbing the data
from the spreadsheet
in a two dimensional array.
We're doing a little
bit of processing here.
We're moving the first row,
which is just the column names,
filtering out the rows
they're already completed,
mapping each row into a
string, putting them together
into a message, and
then returning them
to Hangouts Chat.
WESLEY CHUN: What?
I don't see any auth
or API calls here.
CHUAN JI: That's a very
good question, Wes.
So notice how, I mean,
in terms of API calls
just like the translate
bot, all the API calls
are just function calls.
It's just
SpreadsheetApp.openById,
Spreadsheet.getDataRange,
getValues, get URL.
And that's it.
You're not doing complicated--
You're not building REST
requests or using SDK.
You just call them as
if they're built in.
And in addition, you
don't have to write
any explicit
authentication code.
So obviously, this
spreadsheet is [INAUDIBLE]..
It's not publicly visible.
But because I've
used this before,
I have given access to it.
And Google Apps Script is
responsible for handling
all of that.
You don't have to
write a call back.
store the auth tokens.
You don't have to refresh them.
It's all taken care
of Apps Script.
So after the user logs
in for the first time,
Apps Script will
take care of it.
So, so far, the bots you've seen
collect data and return them
in plain text.
But let's take a look at
how to present a richer
UI in the form of cards.
WESLEY CHUN: Right,
while it's true
that plain text is the
easiest and fastest.
But you've got to
use cards to make
your response look good, right?
So that's what this is for.
So you can use JSON markup
to construct the UI card.
And the best part is that
it's write once, run anywhere.
Web, iOS, Android,
they're all covered.
You don't need to write
a separate mobile version
of your bot.
Cards can be interactive
like the poll you see here.
Users interact by clicking
on the vote button.
Cards are also updateable.
So when users submit votes, the
bar chart and the vote count,
they update.
Now, the user
experience would be
much worse if a new card was
generated for every vote,
right?
The bot framework supports
a variety of widgets.
So here are a couple to
get an idea, like buttons,
formatted text, structured
data, images, links, and more.
But really, the widgets
are just building blocks.
The real magic is when
you put them all together
and assemble them into
cards, whether they're
interactive, updating, or both.
All right, so Chuan, let's
see a demo of a bot that has
interactive and updating cards.
CHUAN JI: All right,
cool, let's go to demo.
Great, thank you.
So it's a great day here today
at Shoreline Amphitheater.
How many of you have been to
Shoreline Amphitheater before?
OK, some of you.
That's more than I
expected, actually.
But for the rest of you,
I just wrote a little bot
that helps us find Shoreline
Amphitheater on Google Maps.
So I call it the Where Is bot.
And I'll just use it like this.
Where is Shoreline Amphitheater?
And what this spot
does is pull up
a map that shows
Shoreline Amphitheater.
And it shows an
image of the map.
WESLEY CHUN: I don't see
any amphitheater there.
CHUAN JI: All right.
On the bottom, you can
see a row of buttons.
And guess what happens.
WESLEY CHUN: I
don't see it still.
Oh wait, there it is.
CHUAN JI: There it is.
So the plus button zooms in
and the minus button zooms out.
So we can see the Bay
Area in all of its glory.
WESLEY CHUN: What's that
Google Maps icon down there?
CHUAN JI: Right, so when
you click on this button,
on web it will take you to
the Google Maps site centered
on the location I typed.
And on mobile, it will,
of course, take you
to the Google Maps App.
Cool.
Would you like to see
how this is built?
Let's go back to the slides.
So here at the
first, we're going
to start with our familiar
on-message function.
So as you guys already know,
the on-message function
is invoked when the user
sends a message to the bot.
In this case, I said, where
is Shoreline Amphitheater.
So its job is to
return the card.
But in this case, we're going to
move the logic for constructing
the card into a new
function we're going
to show called Build Message.
We'll just note here
that Build Message
takes in three arguments.
It takes in the
location of user typed.
This is argumentText.trim.
So we move the space.
And it's going to take
initial zoom level.
And it's going to take in
a third parameter, which
is the response type.
So when a new
message is sent, we
want to send a new
message always.
So we just use new message type.
We'll take a look at that later.
So now let's look
at Build Message.
This is kind of the
meat of the code.
As you saw before, it takes
in location the user typed.
It takes initial zoom level.
And it takes in
the response type.
So what we're going
to do in Build Message
is that we're going to construct
each element, or each widget,
inside this card in sequence.
So we start with the header.
As you can see, just
like the header,
the other widgets are the same.
All of these switches
are represented
by a plain JavaScript object And
the header has two properties.
There's a title,
and it has an icon.
So next, we're going to build
the image that we see here,
the map image.
We'll take a look at how
that's built in the next slide.
And then we'll construct
a row of buttons
that you see on the bottom.
So now here we're going to
have write create in two more
functions, build
Google Maps link, which
takes in just a location.
And we're going to
have a function called
build button, which takes
in the label, the location,
and the target zoom level
that the user will be taken
to when they click the button.
So finally, we're going
to put it all together
into one big JSON object.
And we return this object
back to Hangouts Chat.
And that creates the card.
So let's look at each
of these widgets.
First, let's look
at build image.
It shows an image from Google
Maps in an image widget.
So in this example, we're
going to use the Google Maps
API, which you might notice is
again built into Apps Script.
We just say, maps
on new static map.
We set a bunch of parameters,
like location zoom level,
add a marker, that's the
little red pin you see there.
And you can just
grab a maps URL.
All right, pretty simple.
It's just a function call away.
And then finally, we're
going to take the URL
and construct a JavaScript
object that represents
the image widget and return it.
So next we're going to
build the zoom buttons.
Remember that these zoom
buttons are interactive.
So in addition to creating
the UI side of things,
we're going to add a text button
which contains a text label.
We're going to have
an OnClick parameter.
What's inside the
OnClick parameter?
It's going to be the payloads
that we want sent back
to our bot when a user interacts
with one of these buttons.
So here we're going
to set two parameters.
It's going to put the
location the user typed
in the beginning and
the new zoom level
that the user will be taken
to when they click the button.
So like I said, this
object, or this payload,
is going to be sent
back to our bot
when the user
clicks this button.
So where do we
receive this payload?
You receive it in the
function called OnCard click.
So just like OnMessage, which
is triggered when the user sends
a message, OnCard click is
triggered when a user clicks
on a button in a card.
So what it receives is
the payload of the button
that the user clicked.
So we can extract
the parameters that
were assigned to the button,
and see we extract a location.
We extract the zoom level.
We do a little bit of math to
make sure the zoom level isn't
out of bounds.
And then, guess
what, we just called
the same build
message function that
constructed the initial card.
The only difference is
that this time we're
going to set the parameter
to update message.
Because what we want is
not to post a new message.
We just want to update
the original card
the user clicked on.
So finally, we have the
icon on the bottom left that
takes the user to Google Maps.
So like the zoom buttons,
it's going to create a button.
But it's not going to have
an OnClick handle or payload
that will be returned to the bot
because we don't want the bot
to be invoked.
We just want to send the
user directly to Google Maps.
So here we construct
a link to Google Maps.
And then we attach it to
the Open Link property,
which just instructs
Hangouts Chats to not
deliver the response
back to the bot
but just call up Google Maps.
OK, so I want to stress that
while this example shows you
how to build this kind of
interactivity in Apps Script,
this functionality is not
limited to App Script.
The same functionality
is available
as well if you build your bot
using HTP endpoint or a cloud
pops up endpoint.
So what this really
means is that you
can build the same rich
user experience with cards
in the language of your
choice and deploy it
to the environment
of your choice.
So far we've shown you bots
that respond to something
the user does.
Or the user has
to send a message
or click on a button for
your bot to do anything.
But what if the
bot needs to notify
the user about something?
WESLEY CHUN: All right,
so thanks, Chuan.
So the framework supports
asynchronous messages
which are perfect
for long running jobs
or out-of-band notifications.
Asynchronous
messages can also be
sent to specific
threads for contacts.
So here our bot need to
contact Hangouts Chat.
So some OAuth is needed.
All right, so when
you see OAuth,
it's a strong indication
you're using an API.
So there's no exception
here as a bot has
to call into Hangouts Chat now.
So this Python sample uses
the bot's permission scope
plus a service
account credentials
that you got downloaded
from your API project.
And then once you
have the credentials,
you establish a service
endpoint to the API,
like you see with the
discovery.build call.
And then you can use
the API to send messages
to a DM or a room.
Now, like any other bot,
this bot can call other APIs.
Or it could do any
other processing
that you want to have
it done and then collate
the information and
then send that back
into the room with the DM.
All right, more generally,
besides just creating messages,
the API can do all CRUD
operations on messages.
It also has additional features
to give you more context,
like getting information
on room and DMS or members
who are in room and DMs.
In addition to the
API, Hangouts Chat also
supports in-coming web hooks.
Now these are great
for one-off alerts
like when a server goes down.
They're quick and dirty
or quick and easy.
And you can integrate with
any of your custom workflows.
And the way you do it is you
go to the Room with a DM.
And you pull down
configure webhooks.
And then from there, you can
see all the current webhooks
that are currently defined.
And you can have
different ones because you
may have different apps that
are posting different alerts.
So you just click on
the icon to the right
to copy the web hook
you're able to use.
Now in-coming webhooks
can come from a variety
of sources like monitoring
apps or even the command line.
So Chuan's going to prove this
by doing an incoming WebHook
from a cURL command.
CHUAN JI: All right
thank you, Wes.
All right, let's get to demo.
Thank you.
So as Wes showed
you, the way you
configure a webhook is
you go to a room, click
on configure webhooks.
And we're going to
see a dialog here
that shows you the webhooks
that you've configured.
You can have a URL
here that you can use.
So in this particular
case, to just give
you give some context, let's
say we have an imaginary Task
Manager app.
And it just wants to
send a quick notification
into Hangouts Chat
when something happens.
So I'm going to switch
to a terminal here.
And here you can see
I pasted the command.
It's going to be a cURL command
sending an HTTP post request.
It's going to contain
a JSON payload.
That's the header here.
And it's going to contain the
URL I copied from the dialogue
from Hangouts Chat
in the background.
And the text I'm going
to send, remember
this is the same
payload, the same JSON
object, that you would
send from Apps Script
or from an HTTP request.
It's the same JSON format.
So you just send us a payload.
And let me hit enter here.
And if the thing goes
well, so you can see here,
before we close
the terminal, you
can see that I've
gotten back a response,
a JSON formatted payload from
Hangouts Chat that shows me,
among other things, the
ID of the message that
was just created, the space that
it was posted in, and so on.
So now let's take a look at
this message in Hangouts Chat.
As you can see here, this
created a new conversation.
And it contains the text
that we had just sent to it.
Let's go back to the slides.
So one of the most innovative
features in Hangouts Chat,
as Mike explained
to you guys earlier,
is threaded
conversations, right?
So threaded conversations
are great for grouping
relevant context together.
So in the context of our
imaginary Task Manager
app, what we really like
to see is the history
around a particular
task grouped together,
kind of like the top
thread you can see here.
So what this means is that
all the relevant discussions
from people, all the relevant
notifications from this app,
get grouped into the
same conversation.
So it's very easy for people
to understand whats going on.
So how do we do this?
Just like you saw
before on my screen,
after you send a request
to Hangouts Chat,
we return the data,
the IDs, and so on,
about the messages created.
So you can remember that.
You can remember the association
between task ID and the thread
ID.
And that's perfectly fine.
There's nothing wrong with that.
You can totally do that.
But since this is a
really common use case
we felt we could make
it more convenient.
So the solution we came up with
is the idea of a thread key.
So you can think thread
key as a custom identifier.
It's a [INAUDIBLE]
to Hangouts Chat.
But it's some identifier
that makes sense
to you in your problem domain.
So for example, in
our Task Manager app
it could be a task ID.
If you have a customer
ticket tracking system,
it could be a custom ticket
ID, maybe a customer order ID.
It doesn't matter.
And what you do with it is
just specify in each request
that you make it
when you're creating
a message in Hangouts Chat.
And we do the heavy lifting.
We will remember this.
The first time we see a message
that has a particular thread
key, we will create
a new conversation.
Subsequent messages get posted
into the same conversation.
So now you don't
have to remember
that mapping between an
entity in your problem domain
and a thread or a
conversation in Hangouts Chat.
So of course, this
example here on the slide
shows you are cURL command,
which is very simple.
But this of course, doesn't
just work for incoming webhooks
or from cURL.
This works for bots as well.
So you could write as a bot
and could use thread key
to do the same group conv--
group messages into
the same conversation.
All right, so this wraps
up our introductory tour
of the Hangouts
Chat bot framework.
And I'll hand it off to Mike to
take us across the finish line.
MIKE SORVILLO: Thank
you, Wes and Chuan.
Just to summarize what
we talked about today, so
the Hangout Chat
service with bots
helps teams accelerate
their team and productivity.
You can stay notified, automate
tasks, query information, all
without changing any contexts.
And like they
showed you, there's
many different ways to connect.
You can spin up
your own web service
using any cloud or
language you want.
You can use Cloud
Pub/Sub to work
with a firewall inside
your organization.
Or the easiest way, if
you're building a custom bot
to streamline a workflow,
is using Apps Script
where you don't have to
worry about servers, auth,
or anything like that.
So to get started, check
out developers.googl
e.com/hangoutschat for
more documentation on how
to actually do all of this.
If you're a G Suite customer and
you haven't tried Hangouts Chat
today, you can go
to chat.google.com
to try the product itself.
And if you have more
questions, we're
happy to answer them
in Dome B. We'll
be giving some more demos.
And we could show you
some more details on how
to publish bots and whatnot.
So before we all leave,
we want to hear from you.
So please provide
feedback for the session
at google.com/io/schedule.
And thank you for all coming .
Enjoy the rest of
the conference.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]